PowerPoint karaoke is essentially a
process where you get a set of slides
that you have never seen before and you
have to give a presentation based on
those slides and there's a you can
either get them from co-workers or you
can find them randomly on the Internet
or you can ask a loved one or something
to put it together there's a great
resource if you go to humor dot me slash
PPT karaoke and we'll drop the link in
the chat after I kind of demonstrate it
uh that you can kind of just get random
ones on the internet for you so you can
kind of set this up and do it yourself
but I'm going to demo what that kind of
looks like right now
um to get started can someone give me a
suggestion of a topic that I should give
this short presentation on suggestion of
a topic you neither say it out loud or
drop it in the chat
skateboarding okay fantastic be my
presentation on skateboarding uh so the
PowerPoint karaoke these are the rules
you get a total of 10 slides roughly you
can spend 15 to 30 seconds on each one
you advance the slide yourself and then
when you're playing it as a game you can
rate your friends on Flow gesture
targeting credibility Etc so
um you start with a random number
generator and then you stop that's just
to help you pick some random slides uh
then we go there and that's playing a
little bit earlier this I think the
slide is potentially start on so here we
go uh so this is going to be my
presentation my PowerPoint karaoke
presentation on skateboarding ladies and
gentlemen welcome to this presentation
on skateboarding where we're going to
talk about technological advances in
skateboarding way back in the day you
had simple things like skateboarding
when it first started they didn't even
have round Wheels right the technology
was so bad it was Square wheels that
they're on that's what the scare
represents but now technology is so
great that we can even record
skateboarding on our phones and so we've
seen an explosion of skateboarding
happen because of really cool
skateboarding videos that people have
recorded on their iPhone right so that's
the technological transition when it
comes to skateboarding now if you think
about
the Allure of skateboarding it does
capture people's attention if you see
someone doing some really cool tricks if
they do an ollie or a 360 or a flip or a
720 and a half pipe or whatever people
are gonna watch even if they're doing
business work even if there is a rocket
launch going on TV if you were to do a
kickflip right next to them people would
be like that rocket is cool but so is
that kickflip right they're gonna be
that excited that's the power of
skateboarding these days and so we have
to think about the intersection of
Technology when it comes to
skateboarding right at the middle of
narcissism stalking and ADHD you have
Twitter
the owner of Twitter
and you have people posting about
skateboarding on Twitter right so you
have all of that so there I'll have to
admit there has to be a little bit of
narcissism to do skateboarding you have
to think you know what I'm so much
better at walking I can do it on Wheels
right that's how good you have to be
good so you have to have a little bit of
narcissism a little bit of stalking as
well you have to go to a place over and
over and over again and if you want to
get really good at someone try chasing
them or being chased right if you go to
the Back to the Future style things if
you get chased by someone on a
skateboard that's another way to kind of
get a little bit better and then ADHD
right we want to see different tricks
you need to practice different tricks
the same ones over and over again but
when we watch them we need to see them
because we all have a little bit of ADHD
and we want to see that the flexibility
a little bit so uh who loves
skateboarding everyone in this picture
right uh you see in this picture you've
got Barack Obama you got Angela Merkel I
think that might be macron right there
I'm not entirely sure it's a little hard
to see from here but everyone from
dignitaries down to little kids they
love skateboarding this is something
that excites everyone from top to bottom
and even animals they have different
animal reactions to being in a box and
being on skateboarding right you don't
want to put yourself into a box right
this is more of a uh kind of a a
metaphor for what I'm talking about
right you don't want to put yourself in
the boxes only a skateboarder right
because different animals are gonna have
different reactions but
you can skate around that box you can
think outside the box you can do a rail
ride against the box right there's so
many things that you can do with the box
when it comes to skateboarding and like
I said technological advantages have
come a very long way uh right there are
some skateboards that have electricity
on them I'm guessing is that
um that might be uh is that Tesla that
might be Tesla uh right if you think
about the original OG four-wheel uh
vehicle that is good for the environment
it's not an electric car it's not a
Tesla it's skateboarding right
skateboarding it is man powered human
powered woman powered uh thing powered
right way better for the environment as
well and this is where we are right
we're down at the base right we're at
the base of where this could be and
we've burned the Midnight Oil way too
long by doing these other modes of
transportation where we really need is
this skateboard so as we start to
summarize this is a great chart for the
day that you can do skateboarding if you
think out early morning you're not going
to skateboard right out of bed you got
to brush your teeth and stuff like that
but your morning can you could be pretty
good and then maybe it gets a little bit
slower during the day as you get a
little bit tired and then as you get
towards the end you're gonna have to
fall asleep again although some people
do fall asleep on their skateboard also
nice to note that this would also make a
very good ramp to skateboard awesome
so in conjunction uh let it all out
there right you gotta relax you gotta be
feline fine to jump on a skateboard
right you've got uh you gotta cut grab
out there uh you've gotta be for real to
jump on a skateboard and ultimately it's
gonna make your life that much better
all right there are some answers that
can't be a question or some questions
that can't be answered by Google one of
those questions is should I skateboard
and the answer is unequivocally yes
thank you so much for listening to my
presentation
that is a game of PowerPoint karaoke
again a simple way of getting some
slides you get a suggestion from the
audience and then you just kind of Riff
on the presentation I will tell you it
is a lot of fun to do it's also a fun
thing to watch right so it's just a
thing you could like if you come home
from work could be a thing that you do
with kids it could be something that you
do uh to yourself kind of thinking
through ideas but different improv games
are just simple ways to bring a little
bit more levity a little bit more fun
Bianca is dropping in the chat the link
so that's a link to someone that they
just put up on GitHub uh a way that you
can kind of use your own PowerPoint
karaoke uh do your own PowerPoint
karaoke one of the easiest resources
that we found